[Music]
check it out big celebrity news it's big
it's being reported that Snooki is
pregnant have you heard this yeah yeah
yeah when Rick Santorum heard the news
he immediately came out in favor of
birth control
if more than a joke I'd prefer I like
the audience's reaction - Snooki is
pregnant I didn't say a monster's loose
well yeah but I mean in nine or ten
months eventually seriously it has been
reported that Snooki is three months
pregnant yeah
doctors say the young life form swimming
in fluids with only minor brain
development is gonna have a very healthy
baby
I can see people like I get outlines I'm
swimming in fluid yeah see don't bring
up that cart oh come on that's the best
part
hey that was some primary last night a
gang better Snookie man we gotta talk
about something we'd prefer smokey Mitt
Romney won a squeaker in Michigan last
night and today in a suburb of Detroit
Mitt Romney asked supporters to donate
money to his campaign yeah
of course then the people pointed out
that they live in Detroit and he's MIT
Romney I wonder how that would oh yeah
you fellows mind right here in the Rust
Belt Rick Santorum did not do well with
women last night some say that hurt him
yeah I mean in the votes I didn't do
well with women last night either
oh really doesn't make sense no Rick
sent for me he's having trouble
connecting the food on voters in the
speech last night Rick Santorum tried to
repair his image with female voters yeah
although it didn't help that the speech
started out with listen up [ __ ]
shocking story I couldn't believe this a
new report says that an increasing
number of medical students are paying
off their med school loans with
prostitution yeah
which explains why during my last
physical my doctor was also naked
unless they don't examine to me and I
examined him what is that
what was that I just did that and I
don't know if I shut up that uruk's my
new thing and it's gonna sweep a nation
yeah
[Music]
there's a guy up there doing it and it
looks weird when you sit down
don't do it so ring I swear to god it's
one's gonna come to me the street in the
next couple days ago hey Kona no I'm not
gonna have forgot what they're talking
about looks like you're starting up push
mower yeah let's have that kind of feel
to it you'll see it's gonna be big with
kids kids love mowing yeah stupid kids
scientists are looking into the world's
oldest murder case a man who was
murdered 5,000 years ago
yeah Larry King immediately came forward
with an alibi
[Applause]
any fans of musicals here oh I'll give
that alone they've begun casting a
Broadway musical about Tupac Shakur
that's true
no surprises so far Matthew Broderick's
Tupac Nathan Lane is Biggie Smalls
ray IgG big news folks
tomorrow Justin Bieber turns 18 there's
a big relief for me cuz starting
tomorrow my Justin Bieber backpack and
matching lunchbox doesn't seem so creepy
anymore
[Applause]